marcia recién ha abierto su nueva tienda
de computadoras ella gana 27 dólares por
cada computadora que vende y sus costos
mensuales son 10 mil dólares cuál es el
mínimo número de computadoras que
necesita vender en un mes para tener
ganancias piensa por un momento en el
problema
pensemos que tenemos que calcular
tenemos que calcular el mínimo número de
computadoras que necesita vender
establezcamos una variable para
representar esto sea x igual al número
de computadoras al número de
computadoras vendidas ahora pensemos
cuál va a ser su ganancia neta en un mes
pues lo que nos están preguntando cuál
es el mínimo número de computadoras que
tiene que vender para tener una ganancia
neta podemos entonces establecer que sus
ganancias sus ganancias van a ser igual
al número de computadoras que vende por
27 dólares que ganan cada computadora es
decir 27 dólares por equis que es el
número de computadoras que vende 27 por
equis pero también tiene costos también
tiene costos de 10 mil dólares
estos costos hay que restar se los menos
10 mil dólares ahora bien como queremos
que haya ganancias queremos que este
número sea mayor que 0 calculemos
entonces
el número de computadoras que hace que
la ganancia sea cero y si marcia vende
una computadora además entonces tendrá
una ganancia neta veamos cuando cubre
los costos cuando los ingresos y los
costos son iguales las ganancias son
cero así es que en este caso tenemos que
cero es igual a 27 x menos 10.000 ya
hemos resuelto ecuaciones de este tipo
antes podemos sumar 10.000 a ambos lados
sumamos entonces 10.000 a ambos lados
para que desaparezcan del lado derecho
que resulta de esto ahora nos queda que
10.000
diez mil es igual a 27 x podemos dividir
ahora entre 27 ambos lados de la
ecuación vamos a hacer lo dividimos
entre 27 del lado izquierdo al dividir
entre 27 el lado derecho se cancelan los
27 y nos queda tan solo x voy a escribir
aquí arriba la ecuación nos queda x es
igual a 10.000
entre 27 e intercambie el lado derecho y
el lado izquierdo aquí ahora para
calcular el valor de x hagamos la
división así que 27 que divide a 10.000
ahora 27 no caben 127 no caben 10 27
caben 100 3 veces ahora 3 por 27 esto es
3 por 27 es 81 restamos 100 menos 81 y
nos queda 19 bajamos el 0 bajamos el 0
aquí y ahora 27 divide a 190 190 entre
27 esto creo que es 6 6 por 7 42
llevamos 4 6 por 2 12 y 4 16 162 a ver
veamos aquí está la diferencia de esto
va a ser 28 está mal está mal calculado
entonces esto deben ser 7 horas y 7 por
7 49 llevamos 4 7 por 2 14 y 4 18
perfecto esto nos da 190 menos 189 es
igual a 1 bajamos el cero aquí
bajamos el cero aquí entonces tenemos
ahora 10 entre 27 esto no cabe 27 no
cabe en día es así es que esto debe de
ser cero así que 0 por 27 es 0 0 que
restamos aquí ahora
10 - 0 es 10 vamos ahora a los decimales
bajamos aquí un 0 ya después del punto
decimal y 100 entre 27 es igual a 3 y
así seguiría la división
así es que x es igual más bien
aproximadamente igual a 370 punto 3 pues
aquí seguiría la expansión decimal pero
con esto ya tenemos información
suficiente para responder a la pregunta
cuál es el mínimo número de computadoras
que necesita vender en un mes para tener
ganancias bueno no puede vender un
número decimal de computadoras no puede
vender un tercio de computadoras puede
vender 370 computadoras 370 computadoras
pero con esto no cubriría los costos
pues este es un número menor a 300 70.3
la cantidad que necesita para salir a
mano por lo que necesita vender 300 71
computadoras necesita vender 3
71 computadoras para tener ganancias